there we go there you go
so everybody beware there we go
you're being recorded
absolutely on your best behavior folks
so we're on there
watch
all right um my name is yan lei and yan
li peng
and um i'm very honored again uh to be
here today um
my you know normal job is a data
scientist in a non-profit
organization which is blue cross blue
shield of north carolina
um i uh also volunteer you know to
all those uh you know not uh you know
variety of different community works
uh especially our local you know data
science groups like pi data triangle
um i used to attend several different
meetups in western salem for the past
several years because i used to live in
western salem um and
but now here here i am at i'm i'm so
glad i'm here thank you guys
great
all right
so let's go ahead and get started
because we're already um
at 6 10 now so
today is our november session of
pi data triangle
meetup and we have two presenters today
um um
i'm so
glad that i have the opportunity to
introduce both um the first presenter
gonna be amanda
um
let me try
to
um
excuse me okay
let me try to not rotate my
auto play
there you go all right
let's see
but you can still see my slice is that
something yes yeah we can
okay
let's see
so you probably need to unhide all of
the slides so that you can walk through
them
correct uh i don't know why it's not
allowing me to not skip
so right mouse
so select all of them ctrl a
yeah i did
and then right mouse click don't skip
it it says don't it says yeah okay skip
slides go ahead skip slides and then
descend do it and then do it again again
okay sounds good
now we can now we can start from the
beginning yep yep
thank you for the guidance really
helpful
hey no problem mark mark's always there
first time his first time through he's
got your back he's got your back
bear with me of my um
humbleness
all right um
so yeah so november 3rd is today's date
is our november session of the event
event of pi data triangle meet up
um
and
in our uh there are some
okay how i go now okay here
there are some announcements we just
made uh i also wanted to everybody uh to
know uh there are some code of conducts
uh during this event because we really
want uh this uh event to be uh
hosting i mean holding very smoothly uh
remember this is a public forum
everybody um supposed to be
uh
you know speak very friendly
and
you're more than welcome to share your
ideas but in a very friendly way so
if uh
if there's uh some you know
inappropriate uh
you know speech or uh comments i'll have
to you know mute you if you know please
don't mind uh i meet you because um i'm
the host i supposed to handle this
she has the power
all right thank you
so
so here's a uh very
interesting statistical
statistical joke here uh so please don't
be mean right
be above average that's our goal so
so yeah uh and this slide was provided
by uh mark thank you very much mark for
that
and we've had that slide up all the time
and we've really never had anybody be
mean so
nice very nice all nice people
nice
all right so um
i'll go ahead and introduce our first
speaker here amanda newport foster if
hopefully i pronounced your last name
correctly amanda
you can go ahead and mute yourself okay
if you can do that
yep okay okay cool
um amanda has been
a
tremendous uh
senior data scientist that's what i
heard from uh very cast
and
i'm sorry about the backgrounds and
noise i have to close the
door with me
okay coming back
and um
i
emailed amanda earlier today uh
hopefully uh you know i was you know
hope that she can give me some materials
where i can appropriately introduce
herself i mean uh amanda and uh
interestingly uh amanda's you know
was telling me you know what ela it's uh
it's
just uh go ahead and tell people yeah
they're you know
i started off my data science journey
when i found a not so surprising
correlation between the weather in
france and the sales of sweaters at her
first real job after college
during you know
abnormally warm winter
i feel i feel that's a really really
good story
i thank you for that amanda
and
also amanda has been
working with the uh you know as a you
know data science field for uh more than
six years uh uh and she has been working
on her uh digital advising technology
teams in vericast and amanda is the data
science technical lead on the ad
optimization team
and has had a hand in
improving performance on everything from
display video and rich media media ads
to cvt and ott so without further ado
here comes amanda
all right i'll share the amanda
how how can i give the request to amanda
to share her deck
if you just stop sharing um
just stop sharing yeah all right there
we go
all right
so
i
when gene came to ask me um if i was
willing to do a presentation for the pi
data group
this month
i was trying to think of things that i
could talk about and kind of the only
thing that i have been working on for
the past year
is connected tv and over-the-top tv
advertising
um so
i thought i would do a little bit um a
presentation on some of the issues that
i've currently been
um playing around with um i guess a lot
of what i'm presenting today isn't
actually a
finalized productionalized solution to
some of the the issues that we face in
the ctv world of advertising um but i
just found a lot of interesting things
recently excuse me cat
and um
just thought
data people might enjoy them
um so
um the ctv world is
fairly new when it comes to programmatic
advertising
um
as you might expect a website and mobile
app advertising has been around for many
years um
there's a lot of standards that have
been built up over all those years but
now that we're getting internet on our
tv and a lot new platforms have have
come to be
um like roku samsung
lg i'm sure many people here have all
different types of
ctv and ott devices
and different streaming services that
they watch
so
it's really become pretty complicated
space so i just want to talk through
some of the problems and some of the
ways we've been dealing with them
um
i've been in the advertising world for
quite a while so
i wanted to make sure that i define some
terms
before i start talking about them a lot
um
so i'm probably going to use the word
ctv and ott interchangeably and there's
a lot of kind of confusion in the
business about
how you divide the two of them most
people use them interchangeably but
technically
a connected tb is a actual tv set that's
connected to the internet um
by using some kind of device or a gaming
console or it's got built-in
smart tv technology
whereas ott is over the top video
which is content streaming over the
internet and the reason why it's called
ott
is
because technically
um the
the cape it's going over the top of your
cable box so you don't have a cable box
anymore you're skipping the cable box um
you're skipping the
linear tv the antenna
um you're just connecting directly into
the internet that you already have
so it's basically long form meaning
tv shows and movies streamed over the
internet to a connected device
and ott
content can show on any type of device
um it can show on a connected tv or you
can watch it on your laptop or on a
mobile phone
tablet any of that
um so linear broadcast tv
is really legacy tv um
a lot of people still use it but as of
2020 i believe it was
streaming and ott video have taken over
the number of people who still pay for
cable satellite subscriptions or just
watch
analog tv
so
um
that's what i'm referring to if i ever
say linear or broadcast
uh
and then
down below is more advertising terms so
a publisher
is an owner of advertising inventory
um so
you could consider
cbs to be a publisher they own the
content and they own the advertising
slots that are within their content or
cnn on both their website and their
apps and their tv shows um
they are a publisher a content owner who
sells that inventory
inventory can also be resold
and those are also considered publishers
but we'll just skip that fact for now
um so a dsp demand side platform is the
technology platform that um
sort of centralizes media buying for an
advertiser
and so when we're talking about vericast
which is company i work for the company
hosting us today
we are
partially a dsp um
we
work with ad exchanges added networks
um and use real-time bidding um to buy
ad placements on the internet
for the advertisers that are our clients
and that exchange
is
something that we use that hosts all of
the rtb auctions
um and it facilitates the auction buying
um
so veracast works with seven or eight
different exchanges that um
host the auctions that we we buy
inventory from and a bid request is one
single time when uh your tv or your
your website um that you were going to
is
going through the ad exchange and saying
i need an ad here
so bid request is a request for an ad to
be served
um from the publisher to the dsp via the
ad exchange
and then a placement is just an adverse
advertising slot where something will
appear either on the corner of a web
page or um
during an advertising break on a tv show
so that's a lot of terms i just thought
i'd visualize a little bit here
the most important things here
are
this box
here is where veracast lives and this is
the data that i'm working with so we're
a dsp and we work with our clients to
advertisers and then the exchange hosts
the auctions
and the publisher holds the advertising
inventory
so we just work in a loop
together
to serve ads
so the ott ecosystem is a little bit
different from standard
um
in-browser or in-app um ecosystems so
when you have an app like if you're on
a
i don't know
a game or something like crossy road or
something like that um
that at that app
hosts all of its own content it owns the
content and that little um bird going
across the road is um
owned by those
the app publisher whereas when it comes
to ott it's a much more complicated
system
you will have a distribution platform so
your platform is your device or your
service so your desktop computer your
mobile phone your roku device
etc
um and then on that device
you will have um
either oops
either
oh okay
um
either both of these two or just this
one so you will have an aggregator that
you use so your streaming service which
is like sling
zumo philo pluto
and through those aggregators you will
watch the actual content
so cnn tlc all the tv shows and channels
that you want to watch you'll either
view them directly through their own
apps on your distribution platform or
you will watch them via an aggregator
um so
what i said before is that ctv is
relatively new when it comes to digital
advertising and the
um programmatic
advertising framework
um so i just wanted to list some reasons
why um so
some of the challenges that we have
between ctv and standard digital
advertising is that
there are
requirements for how things work in
both on web browsers and within our
standard app stores which are google
play and itunes those are basically the
only ones that anyone uses so those are
the two that have standards that are
enforced
um
there have been many years of
development on these standards and the
means of identifying apps and of
ensuring that they are what they say
they are um
is clear from this standardization um in
ctv you have quite a lack of
standardization
um every new player basically has their
own platform um you've got amazon fire
roku samsung lg they all have their own
platforms
um these platforms did were not built
from the ground up to conform to
ib standards and when i say iab that is
the interactive advertising bureau they
are like the
head body of
advertising standards so they set
everything for how how your app ids
should look
how an ad should
present on your app things like that
um
and these platforms also aren't
set up to work with current measurement
sdks or any other types of sdks that are
standard in other
app stores so
basically
on
normal
apps within google play and itunes
you've got all of these sdks that allow
advertisers to measure whether an ad was
clicked on whether an ad was viewed by a
person
um
and to check for fraudulent activity and
weirdness
the ctv platforms do not have these yet
um there's also
an important one is the way that
advertising works
so in standard video um and display
you usually as soon as you get an ad
request um
we then try to buy that placement um the
ad if we win the auction will be served
pretty much immediately the maximum kind
of average would be about eight seconds
delay but usually it's within some
milliseconds of an auction happening
that ad will come up on your screen
which means like when you're loading
cnn.com
um
the ads load immediately as soon as the
the web page loads whereas when it comes
to ctv and ott
these ads can actually be served 30
minutes
an hour up to two hours three hours
later
if a user pauses their stream
or some publishers will preemptively
put ads up for auction um if you
are watching live football
and an ad break is coming up within the
next five minutes they will put all
those ad slots up for auction they'll be
bought and then they will basically
use what's called server side ad
insertion
which stitches all those ads that one
together and then they can easily place
that within their stream of inventory
so there's a real delay there and that
causes issues with us measuring and with
impression counting so we don't know how
many ads we've actually won
until maybe an hour after we've served
them
um
so
getting into actual data and moving
towards um
what pi data is all about um
the issues with app standardization kind
of present themselves in
mostly
messy
string inventory information
so
with
google play and
the ios app store
you get a app id each app has its own
unique id that id is obvious and within
kind of an easily searchable url for for
us to look it up to make sure it's a
real thing
urls also have standardization as
everyone kind of knows you've got your
protocol your host
your path and
query strings but when it comes to
ctv publishers they send us through
a lot of junk um so
this is these are all um bundles is what
they're called so this is an app bundle
id
that's just how they're referred to
um but that is also what they refer to
in the ctv space but
one app bundle does not mean one app
so all of these things
are referring to pluto tv
but they are all
over the place
um so sometimes
this here is a real
bundle id and this one here is a real
bundle id
but
this one is not it's gobbly [ __ ] and um
this one
you couldn't
obviously tell that this was pluto
because there's no string in there
saying pluto and it is not an official
app id
so there's not really any way of
figuring out what this is another
interesting thing that happens with ctb
is that publishers will put the exact
channel that someone's watching
so if you remember from this graph
we've got our aggregators here
and that is the actual app hosting the
content but sometimes they'll tell us
which channel the user is watching and
sometimes they won't um so in these
cases here they're saying this oops this
person is watching the johnny carson
channel this person is watching people
tv on pluto
um so
in just a five hour period i looked at
we received 116 different bundle ids
that are meant to refer to the same app
um
so
iab as i said before builds standards
for advertising and they have actually
defined standards for how each of the
app stores ids should look
and so these are some examples of what
they're supposed to look like
but
as shown oops
they actually look like this
only very few of them conform to the
standards
um
yeah so some other issues that we have
it's all naming related basically and
inventory
string related um
there are lots of other interesting
things about ctv space but this was uh
one specific one that i've uh that we've
been working on most i guess
um so
in the bid stream you will get
an app name that the publisher says
this is the name of the particular app
i'm sending you
um no matter what the the kind of bundle
id is that i'm sending you this is its
name um a lot of times we'll get stuff
like this where it's just a random
auto-generated name
a bunch of
letters and numbers
also
we have
differences in
publisher names even though
most of these are the same publisher
they are listed differently on our
different exchanges so ew scripts
company and scripts broadcasting are
actually the exact same publisher with
the same content but they have
completely different names
um only one thing shared there um
same with fox
and then each um
app store actually lists the names
differently as well
um and there's a lot of sort of string
manipulation you can do with this stuff
but it's
it's
difficult to do anything fool proof
um so
one thing here is these two look like
they're the same but this one has an
apostrophe and this one has
like a slightly different type of
apostrophe so they're not actually the
same
but if you just like
keyword search for sling tv you actually
might not catch this one depending on
how you're doing it but this one only
lists the app is sling
um if you cut off everything after your
first kind of
[Music]
punctuation type then you would still
keep all of this
watch live tv sports and tv
um
yeah so those are some of the issues
this is a little bit of a portion of a
bid request looks like when it comes to
us
it's just a long dictionary of data
about the request itself usually
containing device information um
inventory information
location information
um
and some
uh this is just to illustrate that some
are more specific than others
so this one's a something on pluto we
have no idea what channel but
it's some kind of musical and it's pg-13
so who knows what it actually is but
it's a musical i guess
um this one here is a little bit more
descriptive it is
this app id which is filo
and this is one that we would easily be
able to match in the store
and even better they've sent us the
store url that we can scrape and learn
everything about the app
and it's actually telling us that it's
love in paradise which is i think a
hallmark movie from a few years ago
um it's two hours long and it's rated g
um so that's a lot more information on
that second one
um so what do we want to use this data
for um
most the top one is that we use it for
placement optimization which is what my
team does
um we
aggregate data um
up to a higher level
so we can make sense of it
be able to predict things about it
predict its performance based on
viewership based on whether the
ads get completed so if someone watches
it all the way through based on whether
someone clicks on it things like that
um
and we also try to control for frequency
um i'm sure a lot of people here have
had the experience with
streaming services where
you watch the same ad over and over and
over again um liberty mutual is a famous
one with their emu
so
people get tired of and actively start
disliking you if you show them the same
ad over and over and over again so
that's something that clients are really
concerned about and that's something
that that we want to do um very well and
we do it pretty well now but it could be
done better if we got
better uh
at understanding all of our inventory
really well
um inventory selection so a lot of
clients who are from broadcast linear tv
expect to be able to choose which
channels they serve on so i only want to
serve on
local news at a certain time of day
because i want the highest number of
users
to be watching my ad
so being able to select based on channel
is actually surprisingly difficult
because a lot of times the aggregator
apps will not tell us what channel is
being watched
so
that is something that we are actively
working on
we also want to be able to report nice
clean names so in this example we've got
this
varying names that are just it just kind
of looks messy to have
the same apps with different names that
are all very similar
um
so cleaning that up is important for our
clients
they also want to be able to look at
which inventory had good performance um
and
most interestingly we really want to be
able to assign contextual and interest
data to
households as much as possible
um so what can we learn about our
different households from the channels
that they watch which would allow us to
personalize advertising more
to
their interests
um so
the data we get from the bid stream
um it's also from a lot of third-party
vendors so
we get a lot of ad data or app data from
third-party vendors
around
content on those apps
whether it's brand safe or not
we also can learn the true app names
rather than having the messy app names
that come from bitstream
and we can also learn about app
ownership so
which company owns the production of
this app is it something that our
clients would want to target
and then we also have our own app store
scrapers that we run internally that do
slightly different things
and we scrape some websites
that allow us to obtain publisher
information
so this information is used to determine
whether
publishers are verified to be owners or
verified resellers of content
um we want to make sure that we're not
serving on anything fraudulent
um that would not be good
um so our pipeline right now is that we
aggregate up our bid data to placement
key
um
we make sure the seller's verified
we apply some human readable or kind of
a grouping app name from a third-party
data set
as listed before
um and from our app store scrapers so
this
currently only covers about 30
of the ott requests that come through
bidstream
um so that is the app id bundle id
problem that i've been talking about
our app store scrapers only list data by
those app ids um so if we don't have an
id
we can't know um what the like official
information is about that app
um
so for ones that we're not able to match
by a third party
we do some keyword
slicing and matching
and some string
manipulation
and then our apps are ready to be or our
placements are ready to be used for
allow list creation
for reporting as well as we categorize
them into lists for things like sports
local news
major cable channels spanish language
channels
and we use
content and categorization data from our
third parties
keywords to be able to
divide up all those lists
so keyword and string matching is the
main way that we go about
matching these uh bundles that don't
have the correct bundle ids
so there's a bit of manual maintenance
required around this
um
so
first off there's always the existential
question of what is ott inventory
there is
no
flag
in the data that tells us that this
specific thing is over the top tv so
would you consider
user generated content on youtube that
is
it's 30 30 minutes long so it's
basically tv show length but it's
technically not considered
ott i guess technically is isn't the
correct word but it's not generally
considered as ott because it is user
generated and it is not generated by a
big production house
um by one of the well-known names
um so
we have our display names and our
kind of names that they match and
uh common nicknames for things
um and we use these to be able to label
our inventory
this is obviously not foolproof and
definitely not easily maintainable
so these are all keywords that were
extracted from
the domains the
result bid stream data so from the
domain um
the bundle id and from
the
app name inventory that was sent to us
through
from the publisher
um so
in
late summer i think we had a bit of a
breakthrough
um
or something came to the ad optimization
team's attention that the
our user graph team had been dealing
with for a long time
so
our user graph people are extremely
smart and
they
are the maintainers of our
user graph where we kind of match people
together and match people to the
households that they belong to
i shouldn't say people i should say
devices
so we kind of work at the device level
so
our user graph team was noticing that
these mobile advertising identifiers as
they're called or maids
um
they were causing they were finding some
that were causing problems for our graph
building process
they were finding loads and loads like
thousands and millions of unique
um
ad ids from mobile devices
that were um being matched to the same
kind of locations but they were
exploding the size of our user graph
adding like no useful information but
just exploding things in size making it
difficult for things to run and all of
that
so
for a little background
mobile apps themselves mobile devices
outside of browsers don't use cookies
cookies don't exist within apps
so instead advertisers use something on
the device itself called
the
ad id or the idfa depending on what
device you're on
it's provided by the mobile devices
operating system and this is used as a
targeting identifier um
for apple these idfas have become a lot
less common but for android they're
still there for now
um
so these
um mobile app mobile um
ad ids
are generally sent through um an app
um by a publisher whenever you're
generating a bid request so the
publisher will send through the
mobile head id whenever um they're
generating a request
um so
what was happening was
that it seems that most
ott platforms so roku samsung
um
etc
they all use actually app level mobile
ids
which means that every single app on
your platform
is sending through a different unique id
so we are assuming that this device id
applies to one single the apps on one
device
whereas you're getting one device with a
whole bunch
of mobile ad ids coming through to you
so
i just wanted to put a bit of their code
here because they labeled these hey
amanda yeah just a quick question the um
the um
the ad id from android and the idfa from
apple
are those those are subsets of maids is
that a maze sort of covers all of them
yes yeah that's maze is the more general
term it's just mobile ad id
um but android and apple have their own
acronyms for them
but yeah they're subsets of mobile ad
ids in general
um
yeah so
the graph team was labeling these things
as bad
mates
um so i just cut out a snippet of code
because i thought it was funny that they
call them bad users um
when actually when i heard of this
i realized that we could probably use
this for our app identification problems
um
yeah so i
realized that or
thought about how this could be used for
our inventory problems on the
ad optimization side
um hoping we could find a new more
reliable method than keywords and
strings to be able to identify inventory
um so
um
the
initial thing
um was that
uh the graph team looked at building
just a connected components
graphical
algorithm to
detect these networks
and they they had some trouble with it
because they were looking at all apps
across um the universe of apps that we
have
and they were all just connecting to
each other creating some massive
components um that were um
not very useful
but as soon as i filtered it down to our
ott inventory only i actually found that
these graphs created some really cool
structures and some really
helpful um
divisions of um
communities
that we could find so
tried a couple of different
community detection algorithms just
using network x
i
found network x worked really well for
the size of data that we have right now
it may be that as we get more and more
um
ctv inventory coming in um we may need
to move to something that's just more
distributed or distributable
um but now network x worked
fantastically for my purposes
um we were looking at connected
components first
and then
that's just finding communities of all
your nodes that are connected
that's
just trying to divide up your graph into
all the things that are connected
together by their edges
i also tried briefly something called
greedy modularity communities
this is where
you're trying to maximize
modularity
within communities
so keeping together really dense
communities and breaking
weak weak connections
and then i was trying
with the best results was the
an asynchronous label propagation
algorithm
so that basically randomly assigns each
node with labels
and then
labels that are connected tightly um get
to propagate their labels across and
then it eventually stops when
you have the
each one with the most uh
most frequent label amongst its
neighbors so everyone gets divided into
a community based on the ones that
they're most um strongly connected with
um so hey amanda you have a question out
there how big is the ott data set right
now
the one i ran this on was um a thousand
domains
um
so within this there were
um
700
connections
um between things so yeah fairly small
um this was a a sample
but the
maximum size of our ott domain list
right now is um
uh what is it
something like 3 000 unique domains so
it's pretty small data in the grand
scheme of things
when you're talking about our user graph
that is
millions and
hundreds of millions of of ids but when
it comes to inventory itself it is much
much smaller
in the thousands
um
so that's why this stuff was working
really well and i was actually able to
visualize them using the matplotlib
thing
um
whereas anything larger would not really
have been possible
more questions
gaming our data feed
i'm not sure what you mean
um
i i asked the question
what occurred to me uh a few slides ago
was whether or not somebody would
potentially maliciously
put put some
wrong some wrong data or misleading data
into a data feed to cause auctions
to happen that really
shouldn't happen or to to raise the
price of to praise the price of
an analogy would be high frequency trade
the high frequency trader community up
on wall street
that
that that as your
normal trade goes in they they look at
it just milliseconds or microseconds
before it gets to the floor
and they
can insert
their own transactions before yours
that cause your
your transaction to to fail because the
price you saw on your your dashboard
uh really didn't reflect the current
price by the time your transaction gets
your trade gets to the floor of the
stock exchange so i was i was curious as
whether or not somebody
uh
might might try to
you know insert insert data
or confusing data
along the way
just just curious
yeah that's actually a good question and
a slightly separate topic on um the idea
of fraud and ad fraud is definitely a
thing that happens
um so
in these particular cases with these
bundle ids i was showing before
these ones are actually cases where the
publisher thinks that they are helping
by
telling us more information than we need
um so these are cases when this is
tv.pluto um
the app id but they're telling us that
the channel is the johnny carson channel
or that they are using this particular
um device uh like uh let's see
like a vizio device
um
so these ones here are cases where
publishers send through more information
than you need and then is accurate
so a lot of exchanges are actively
trying to get their publishers to stop
putting the information in the bundle id
and start putting it in the proper place
in the request stream however it is
definitely the case that um we actually
call it misrepresented inventory when um
fraudsters really um are putting in um
bids that
don't exist or that are being served
in not the places that they say um so
it's there have been a few um cases that
have come up of of
um i think one of the fraud schemes was
called pareto there have been a lot like
that um
where um
ads were coming up for very popular
channels like you have hgtv you have cnn
and that would be what the app name was
but
it was actually not being served on
any of those it was just being served to
some fake server somewhere um
that is combated by um
a lot of the iab industry standards so
that is why we check
on my list somewhere
whether a publisher is verified
so publisher ids can't be changed and
they can't be faked when it comes to
the exchange
you receive a new publisher id every
time you set up a new account with an
exchange
so your publisher has to be verified
in a document from the iab that you are
allowed to serve that inventory
so that is
why the iub is really important for
preventing fraud
i don't know if there are cases when
like a legitimate publisher
tries to
system
um
on apps that they own
i'm not sure why they would do that
because they might not maybe they would
make money off of that i'm not sure
but nothing um
exactly like what you're talking about
i think ad tech companies are actually
uh a kpi
is
the amount of fraud
um that you can capture and
we're
rated you know against that those
criteria
yep yeah it's definitely been something
that people are on high alert on for
for a long time now and
as ctv is a new space um lots of dollars
are moving there from broadcast from
linear
people are very very sensitive about
misrepresented inventory
and ad fraud
um
yeah so using my
um label propagation
um
community detection um
this is what our ott inventory looks
like
um kind of messy and this is you know
the built-in matplotlib stuff that
graphics has um
but
there's some awesome things about it
um so you've got some really
really super tight clusters um that you
can see
around
where you've got loads and loads of
nodes connected together and you'll see
in future slides a bit more about those
but my favorite thing is that you've got
around the outside loads and loads of
just two
two nodes connected together
and the best thing about this is that
those are all the ads where
we've got one with an official
app ad id
and then we've got one that is a string
that is kind of a
not random string but it's one of those
cases where the publisher tries to give
you too much information and it's
linking those two together so that we
can apply the name of the official app
to that stream
and those are those are my favorite ones
um so just a little bit about
why
why i chose the
asynchronous label propagation
was because it did a better job with
some of our smaller communities
um so you don't really need to read the
names on here i know they're pretty
small but this hey hey amanda i had a
question about the previous slide
what what's the um
what are your x and y axis there
oh yeah how are you mapping that
it just it's just the way that this
graph it's a it's a it's a graph
nodes nodes and edges
or nodes nodes and vertices
yeah so my nodes and relationships
each dot is a
app
bundle id
and then my edges are the user
similarity between them so
um
there are weights assigned to these
edges so maybe this edge these um
users are thirty percent
thirty percent of the users are shared
between these two apps
um
that's what those are um the way that
network x and i'm not an expert on this
but it graphs things based on different
sort of algorithms or it displays them
this is not necessarily anything to do
with how
the graph is
well it is to do with how the graph is
structured but it's just a it's trying
to show them in a way where you can
see things separately
um
yeah
amanda what software are you using for
your your
graph database or your graph
analysis or representation
yeah i'm not actually using um graph
structured data um i'm just using um
hgfs
data that we pull from hdfs and pulling
it into pandas so these are pandas data
frames
where my
first column is the the source node
second column is the destination node
and then my third column is the weight
um so
i
then pull it into a network graph
so
it's it's a graph
in the network x
yes thank you harsh
if you have an edge you are attracted to
each other or else they are repelled so
that's why they kind of push towards the
outside
of the
picture
um
yeah so this was just looking at um
why lpa did a slightly better job
in my use case
it was able to break out this
cluster
whereas the other ones
had them still connected and you could
have just
chopped out these nodes if you wanted to
and you would have had your separate
clusters but
this one seemed to do
an excellent job of not having any false
positives inside of our clusters that we
created
um
so fun thing about this which i didn't
really expect
was that we had a lot of these
star shapes
not sure if that's the official term for
them but
one hub and
lots of nodes connecting to those hubs
so
this is the more generic app name of
fubo on amazon fire tv
and these were all of the other channels
that shared um
users with this generic name
so
this was
a great way of figuring out what the
official app name is and also figuring
out which channels people are actually
watching on fubo tv
same thing with pluto
and this one was a fun one um so
i really liked this
sort of double star structure
um but it shows that you've got your
more generic app names here film rise is
a a big kind of ott publisher of films
um
or content owner of films and this is
their roku
app id
but these are also roku app ids so why
were all these roku app ids having the
same users as this
separate
app
so what it looks like is all of these
app ids i have listed over here
are actually in the film rise
universe
the metaverse of film rise um
it looks like on roku and maybe on some
other
apps or other platforms
oops i think we lost amanda
did we lose her
uh
the cat hit the hat hit some button on
her keyboard
okay while we're still waiting um
why don't we start uh announcing some
announcement mark um do you feel like we
can do that
or we just go ahead and just wait for
amanda to hop in again
is linda shoemaker here
linda
yes i'm here
hey linda i know linda i know linda has
an
announcement
yeah we have a job opening at advanced
auto parts for a data scientist
and it's in the team that's working on
assortment optimization
and we're looking for someone with three
years experience and our environment is
python
spark on aws and it's helpful to be
pretty good at sql as well
so i'll put
i'll put the link in the chat and if you
want to talk to me or
just contact me through meetup
or you can find me on linkedin so thanks
mark
no problem is that is the the this your
group that has the
that's going to be slotting the job
yes it's reporting to me
so
job seekers you know who you're going to
report to
all right thank you so much linda
um
anyone has
anything else to announce
i could
well that's a vericas
say again gene
can you can you hear us gene
we cannot hear you
are you mute no you're not muted
yes i'm not i'm not muted but
can you hear gene
no i cannot hear gene no
something wrong with your headphone
again gene
all right um
i happen to have a uh
real quick uh you know
uh you know uh announcement as well um
blue cross nc uh data science team is
also hiring
um
well i i'm not the hire manager um but
uh just to want to share some
information to you guys uh
you know there is a vp level of data you
know um to lead the data science that
job is open
and there is a there are several senior
levels
of senior data scientists as well
um
so so if you're interested uh you know
search
those um websites right linkedin or
google or uh
you know even the uh official website
from blue cross and c
so hopefully that's helpful
those of us who've worked there uh
pronounce it buck buzznuck
blue cross blue shield and c
[Laughter]
come on mark you know that right
i i
i have worked i have worked there
oh you have okay i didn't know a long
time ago i still go to the old coots
lunch
for former blue cross employees
oh really okay
okay that's good to know because we are
um considering our uh
uh you know uh lunch
uh
meet again this december uh see if we
can make it outside door seating
hopefully
um
but
well wow mark
thank you
all right so so you know what um
let's give it for two
i mean one more minute
and then i'll
go ahead and introduce our next speaker
um
because i don't see why uh both
jean and amanda
something wrong with their network maybe
i don't
know right if uh anyone has any you know
not you know any else anything else of
the announcement go ahead uh share
because uh this is
all the uh networking you know
uh platform we're offering right so also
if you have a live
if you have a lightning talk uh go ahead
and put that into uh you know put that
into the chat so that
john lay can uh start a list of who's
going to be doing lightning talks
absolutely
feel free to leave
you know your ideas in a chat thank you
hey amanda welcome back
hi sorry about that i made the rookie
mistake of not plugging in my laptop
during a presentation
oh that happens
my guess was that your cat had pushed
one of the buttons on the key on your
keyboard and all of a sudden you were
asleep you had gone to sleep and uh you
know the network router had been uh uh
had been reset in the process oh it was
all sorts of crazy stuff
she has turned off my computer before
but not this time it was my own fault i
had probably five minutes left um
yeah um i'm about to say that um amanda
you have uh i think uh
you know up until 7 15 it's all yours so
okay sorry about that you guys got some
admin
time
you missed all the uh fantastic
announcements by the way
oh no
just some hiring uh information we're
sharing
okay
all right so back to my double star
um
i can't remember what the last thing i
said was here but
basically it looks like all of these
apps are interconnected because they're
all owned by film rise
um
so what probably happens here is that
the
app owner themselves set up their own
um rather than having
app level
mobile advertising ids
they actually have um sort of within
their own little app universe they have
their own mobile ad ids
so this is just a really interesting way
that we could connect
um
apps themselves together in different
ways rather than just finding the
correct names of each individual app
um
so
yeah these were just an example of a few
of the communities that were found um so
the things i've highlighted are things
that already have an app name
and then the other things could not be
matched
and
this one's kind of an interesting one
because
it couldn't really super easily be
divided up into
keywords that we could match up against
but this is cbs news cbsn
we would have had to kind of learn how
to divide that out from
ps4 fubo and lg tv
but through this method we can just go
in find that they have all the same
users and um match them together very
quickly and easily
um
same with vizio here it's represented in
a million different ways and these ones
are very unclear what they actually are
but now we can
identify where they come from
so last slide
so for each community that is found in
our label propagation algorithm
we propagate app names to nodes without
names
by taking the name from their highest
weighted neighbor and we just repeat
that process until
no more names are able to be assigned
um
and so when we compared this with
identifying inventory by app store id
alone
um
so with app store matching we can only
match about 36 percent of our uh app
names to apps in our bid requests
this method allows us to expand that to
78
um on
my sort of medium-sized sample of data
and then those final 22 percent are
actually already divided up into
communities that could make it very easy
for us to be able to match them
or to label them either manually or use
our previous keyword process
to be able to
match them to a real app name
so just an example of what one of our
final reports could look like for a
client
we can say that we served on sling tv
and we won't have that sling free tv and
video
long name it'll have a nice clean name
and then cases where they do have a
channel we can just do that keyword
matching to grab the name of the channel
out as well
um and then we have publisher names and
this is just like how many impressions
we served on each one
so
that is all i had
with a brief interruption
any questions or anything
all right q and a time we got uh
four minutes
uh amanda this is mark i was interested
in um
what you think you'll be able to get up
to in terms of percentage accuracy you
you talked about
uh 78 you you've you've upped your game
to 78
and that that the other 22
uh shows promise
uh what what do you expect you're going
to get to in terms of a a final accuracy
percentage
yeah i'm not sure um that was uh where i
stopped um before we um
did this presentation
that's what i was working on this
weekend um so this sprint which just
started two days ago i'm looking into
what that 22 percent um can be matched
with
um
i imagine with the keyword matching will
get
i don't know it would it would be a sort
of random estimate but i'm sure we will
get more with the keyword matching but
there are some that come through is just
random numbers and letters and don't
give us any other information
um
however those ones if they are not able
to be connected to other apps
the likelihood that they are something
we actually want to be serving on kind
of goes down
so it may be that
that stuff we don't really mind losing
it'll depend on like what the volume is
of the final percentage
that we can't match whether we just
leave them be or
find another process to deal with it
all right we have the
time for one more question maybe
if you have any
hey welcome back gene
i see you hop on
back again
yeah i had a cold reboot i mean it my
whole computer crashed it was weird
but um
it's good to be back sorry i missed them
were any cats involved
i don't know what happened
everything everything froze and i had to
hold my finger down on the and the start
button for like 25 seconds
before the thing would reboot it's
really weird
computer epidemiology
it's contagious
because amanda had a similar situation
previously
oh really
yeah it was obvious though it was just i
haven't plugged it in
easily diagnosed
all right um
gene were you uh
going to announce anything
you can go ahead uh i mean uh
oh i i'm not even sure where i left off
i probably went on for like you know 30
seconds or so yeah we have multiple um
data science and engineering
um openings right now we're doing we're
going through an expansion
um at vericast and um
i think that there's a there's a lot of
opportunities um in
raleigh here but um but most of a lot of
our positions are remote
so
anyways spread the word um we're excited
about um
getting into some new projects and
research that we haven't been able to do
and
we have finally getting a chance to do
it
sounds good thank you for sharing uh
amanda i think there is uh one question
coming in in the chat uh is there any
way for me not to be tracked by ads
across devices
very good
one yeah there are ways you can just
kind of google your device and say
disable ad tracking um if you're in
browsers um there are lots of ad
ad blocker softwares you can use
but most ctv um
devices will have settings deep in the
settings um
spot where you can say like disable ad
tracking
you'll still receive ads but they won't
be like
targeted
they won't be collecting and storing
your data
all right
hopefully uh that answered the question
all right let's proceed
with our next tremendous
speaker
harsh parikh parikh
um okay a briefly introduction um
harsh is a
phd candidate in the duke university
at uh
ame lab uh ame stands for
almost
matching actual uh exactly
i hope i hope i remember that correctly
um
uh harsh has received a 2020 amazon
graduate research fellowship
for working on evaluating cultural
methods
and he has been working on
interpretable cultural inference
methodologies
for high stakes decision making
and also harsh recent
work includes
an ongoing development of a steam
simulator based
framework for validating cultural
inference methods at amazon
so without further ado let's welcome
harsh
harsh all yours thanks thanks for
introduction let me share screen and
let me know if you can't see the slides
can you see the slides
yes we can see the size yes we can
amazing uh so i'm just gonna switch
gears from what i'm amanda president
uh i i promise you i won't bore you with
math uh i guess there is hardly any math
in the presentation
but
if you have any questions or would love
to have discussion middle of the
presentation i absolutely appreciate it
in fact i love
discussion during the presentation so
that we don't miss out on interesting uh
points and anecdotes
having said that broadly i work in this
area of causal inference and
i guess most of people
on this call know about machine learning
and what machine learning is used for
and traditionally machine learning is
used to understand
uh if
variable x can predict variable y right
and x can be a vector and predict why
but if you're interested in questions
like does x cause y
so questions such as does vaccine
protect me
against
uh against flu right uh
that's a causal question and that's not
a quotation question and i'll show you
why
that needs slightly
different approach uh in estimation and
so moles is one of such methods which
which does causal inference which allows
you to ask questions does x cos y and
i'll walk you through a case study which
is which is kind of a motivating case
study for this project as well uh and
the question was do self-help groups
help uh
increase
financial risk tolerance in uh in
households right and this this case
study is based on data from india but
you can kind of imagine asking similar
questions everywhere this is joint work
with professor rudin and professor
wolfowski
i bet some of you already know uh alex
uh and maybe he's a
uh
he's a regular pirate i'm not sure he
never mentioned about it so i have no
idea
but i'm i'm
happy alex actually uh actually alex
actually was the uh a guest
speaker at um
i believe it was our
research uh day event and
um it was in august of 2018.
i believe or maybe 19.
um but that's that's an impression yeah
we first heard about malts at that point
that is amazing yeah so those were the
initial days of fault and also initial
days of my phd in 28 i started my phd in
2018 so i've been working on this since
then and uh this has taken beautiful
shape so i'll walk you through the
method and then some of the applications
of it
let's let's get started right away in
the story right
so the story pretty much starts uh
from my personal experience when i was
traveling to
a village in central india and i was
talking to
one of the family uh household uh
members there and they told me that
their father recently died of starvation
i was very curious that in 21st century
someone died of starvation that that
sounds really bad and i asked him what
happened
so he told me a few years ago uh there
was heavy rain and
that destroyed a lot of the crop right
now if your crop is destroyed uh there
is no money for you for left for you for
that year so they borrowed money uh and
because they don't have access to formal
financial institutions like banks banks
would give won't give loans to small
farmers so they would go and
ask for this money from
local loan loan sharks and typically
this low local loan sharks
give you credit and really high interest
rates somewhere around 75 to 100 percent
which pretty much means that you will
not be able to pay the loan back but you
will also be trapped in this cycle of
debt because it will
uh it will kind of deplete your capital
right and 75 to 100 interest rate is too
much
so this this is the classic dead trap
and this is not a one-off story this is
pretty common in a lot of developing
countries where you have small-scale uh
laborers or farmers working uh really
hard
a lot of solutions have came uh come up
to address this one of them is you know
it's the basic income because you kind
of constantly give money to people so
they uh
they have constant inflow of capital
irrespective of their economic cycle the
other is self-help groups
and so these site this idea of self-help
groups is pretty simple
uh
it's a group of 10 to 25
adult women
and
they pull in really small sums of money
so something like 10 dollars a month
kind of thing right and
uh if you imagine 10 a month for 25
people it's 250
uh the pooled amount is reasonably big
however the individual amount is pretty
small
the investors pool amount and let's say
a savings account on which they get
interest
but apart from that because it's a
self-help group account uh government in
india have enabled them to have
collateral free loans and uh loans at
really low interest rate right
now when you when someone is in need of
the money let's say someone one of the
family over here needs to uh needs this
money to cope up with a crisis or maybe
for a wedding ceremony we can borrow the
money uh using this micro loans and but
because of the social pressure and the
peer pressure of other 24 women
they will ensure that they pay this
money back in time it kind of creates
this nice positive cycle where people
can get money when they need it and then
they also pay back on time because of
the peer pressure not default also this
money can be used for health education
and
entrepreneurship which is amazing uh so
this kind of
seems to be solving the problem however
there is very little evidence
uh on the field now now there is more
evidence but back then there was a very
little evidence if this actually works
or not
so this kind of
takes us to our question
does participating in self-help group
increase my financial risk tolerance
right and so the way we have uh
calculated financial risk over here is
if you have an active loan account with
the bank
right that means if you have an access
to active loan account from a formal
financial institution then you're
financially risk tolerant you are happy
taking loan and the bank is happy giving
you loan
so if it's a binary outcome
for each person if the person has loan
then it's one if the person does not
have loan then it's zero and so you can
kind of see you can look at the
percentage of participants uh in
having active loan versus percentage of
non-participants and this is your
classic correlation you can kind of also
do it using machine learning but if you
if you look just as my
at this nine correlation you would say
participants have 63
chance of getting loan while
non-partisan participants have 75
percent
but this doesn't mean that participating
is actually detrimental right
and one of the arguments which
a lot of people have made is
people who do not participate is are
very different population in fact they
might be very often that's why that's
why they might not have participated
right and
hence 75 over here the larger number
over here is because of
this difference in the underlying
population
so what we should actually have asked is
the question
what would be the participants outcome
if they hadn't participated
right if if they had participated we see
what their outcome is
we are interested in a counter factual
in a universe
where none of them would have
participated then what would have
happened how many of them would have
actually ended up with a loan with a
bank
we don't observe that uh however that's
exactly the causal effect so
hypothetically let's say it was 1.5
percent then your causal effect is 60 63
minus 1.5 that's your causal effect of
participation
so to be more formal uh
for a single person for a single unit i
there can be two outcomes one if they
had participated let's call it y1
and one if they had not participated
let's call it y0 right so these are
called potential outcomes potential
because
they
would be realized if
depending on what
choice
unit i makes to participate or not to
participate
and the treatment effect is the
difference of this outcomes
right the treatment effect for unit i is
y i 1 minus pi ac
but there is
a fundamental flaw over here which is
for every unit we only observe one of
these outcomes let's see unit i chose to
participate then we will only observe y
i 1
while y i 0 would not be observed
because
that that unit has not chosen that that
treatment and we'll never be able to do
that so
causal inference is on like causal
effect is unknowable and in fact cause
or influence is a missing data problem
is everyone with me till now
if you have any questions i will just
pause for a couple of seconds
uh are we getting into bayesian
territory here
not at all we will not talk about
beijing or frequentest at all this yeah
but broadly speaking is
are we kind of on the same page about
why we can never know causal effect
from my understanding harsh um
so you're saying
uh for every
unit i
basically you know for example for every
uh person on the trial right they can
only experience
one situation
no matter yeah no
you know no matter which trial
his uh he or she is proceeding with
right so the other possibility gonna be
always unknown so that's
that's the missing part right okay
exactly yeah that's that's the hidden
part that's the missing part for each
person you only observe
one outcome based on your
choice of treatment let's see if it was
t equal to zero then you would only
observe y zero your observed outcome y
would be equal to y c
right and so
that's why it's a missing data problem
causing causal quantity causal effect is
never known and you want to estimate
that
now
there have been
like this is not a new new problem this
problem has existed since like 1500 1600
when
people wanted to know if uh eating
citrus fruits can cure scurvy on
on long haul ships
and people have done causal influence
since then
let's say we are in a situation
where
we are unable to randomly assign
treatment to group one or group two
right because if we were able to assign
random treatments to group one and group
two and let's say we don't treat group 2
randomly and
trade group 1
then
looking at just the average difference
between them is causal effect because we
decided who gets the treatment
who did not
uh
and that's fine that's how vaccine
trials happen people are randomly chosen
into placebo and treatment arms and then
you look at their outcomes
in a lot of situations such as knowing
the effect of smoking on a baby's health
effect of smoking
in a pregnant mother on baby's health
you cannot force people to smoke and not
smoke
people will automatically choose into
one of the one of the treatment groups
so there
either you can do it what you can do is
match people on their pre-treatment
status so something like their age their
income their race their uh neighborhood
like what kind of neighborhood they live
in what's the zip code you can kind of
you match people on
all those coverages which are
pre-treatment and say that hey their
decision of choosing into one of these
treatment arms was based on this
covariate so now when i'm looking
everyone inside this red box i'm
comparing likes with likes
and
any inference that you do is now
constrained within this box right
because you're conditioning on
the the level of treatment so uh you can
compare the greens and the blues inside
this box the other approach is uh
fitting a regression
uh so there are two regression lines one
you can fit for the treated and the
other for the controls so one for t
equal to one on the other for p equal to
zero and then look at the difference of
predicted outcomes
by fitting regression line you are in
essence controlling for the
pre-treatment covariates things which
could have contributed in the choice of
treatment are we on the same page still
awesome
uh sorry a quick question what a
regression um when you compare the two
regressions would you in this case just
compare the slopes um is that the idea
yeah so if you were to do parametric
regressions like uh like linear
regression you can just compare the
slopes and that would give you the
treatment effect the other
version could be that you do a
non-parametric version right so you fit
random forest on the first one and on
the second one now because they're
non-parametric their slopes would change
with
your ex so if you're interested in let's
say knowing the effect of treatment on
everyone who is
age between 15 and 20 then you can just
look at the slope for
uh the difference of predicted outcomes
for people between 15 and 20.
does that make sense
okay yeah thanks thanks for that
explanation right
and so this these are two prime like
broadly primary two approaches there are
other approaches to this but these are
mean to approaches and i don't want to
kind of overload with uh background of
possible influence we will focus
primarily on matching and the argument
over here is a
matching
is very good and b matching can be done
in an accurate way
so why matching right this is this is
the question i need to justify before
even going because there are two
approaches so matching is conceptually
very simple you're not fitting anything
you're not doing anything you're
comparing apples with apples
in in
our classic apples orange our analogy
also because you're looking at things
inside this red boxes
uh and just looking at the average
differences between them you can think
of this as more interpolation rather
than
extrapolation so regression is
definitely extrapolation
in matching you are only looking at
things
which are comparable inside red boxes
without kind of extending beyond that uh
so it's
interpolation you need less assumptions
also if you
were to match directly based on let's
say people's age gender everything then
it's interpretable because now you can
look at each of the match groups and say
oh yeah this
this match group has this treatment
effect because people in this group are
old this match group has this effect
because this people in this group are
female kind of things right so it's
highly interpretable you can actually go
and look at each match group
also
uh there's this whole idea of
sensitivity analysis what if x was not
the complete set of things you could
have controlled but there was another
hue which was missing and you didn't
control for it
how would that bias your results and
that's called sensitive analysis to
another confounding we won't go into
this but with matching you can also do
this uh in a in a very nice way and
you're in the process of writing a paper
about this with doctors at massachusetts
general hospital so i'll kind of focus
on the first three points throughout the
paper
uh and tell you how we do it and uh how
we do it in a in a better way
but so matching this
i convinced you that matching is great
but matching has its own problems
it it's
not that matching a solution to
everything and then it's easy
let's take a toy super toy example of
three units unit one is treated so
they're they're participating in
self-help group p equal to one
uh
they have they have received loan
their occupation is farmer and there for
some reason the surveyor that we sent
out also decided to collect toenail lens
right crazy why would you do that but
they did that
and uh
so unit one stone and length is point
two inches
now let's say
uh one of the experts comes and says
that oh yeah it's super important to
match on toenail lens
you would end up matching u1 with
youtube right because they have similar
two new nets and then you see oh unit
two is not treated uh but they also have
loan
and you say oh
participating in self-help group does
not have any treatment effect it's null
but let's say if someone some economist
comes and says that hey tony lens is
crazy like why would you even match on
that you should imagine occupation of
people and you would match unit 1 with
unit 3 and you say oh yeah
unit 1 got loan
and was treated unit
3 didn't get loan and was not treated
the treatment effect is one over here
the estimated treatment effect is one i
shouldn't say and so this kind of
highlights that the choice of distance
matrix choice of what similar means
really affects your
estimation it's highly sensitive to uh
to the choice of distance matrix
and this is a toy example with three
data sets and like two covariates but if
imagine you have
like 1000 covariates high dimensional
rate or 100 covariates and you have
thousands of points it it's really hard
even for a domain expert to actually
look at the data and say this is the
right covariates to match and this is
the right distance matrix right
so how how have people come acro about
this like around this problem
the easiest solution is just do exact
match match farmers with farmers and
who have seen two nations but as you
just saw in that toyota set
sometimes it's impossible to match
exactly
because for continuous covariates it's
like with probability zero almost zero
you won't find any other unit with the
same
uh
same value also it is statistically very
inefficient right you're throwing away a
lot of units
who might have slightly different uh
values or who who might be different on
unimportant copies
the other option is uh as i mentioned go
to the expert ask them to define a
distance matrix based on some background
knowledge
and match on that
not practical in high dimensional
scenarios because
from my personal experience i can pretty
confidently say experts
mess up pretty well in high dimensional
scenarios
the other two options are
in literature which people have commonly
used or match on
matched to people who have same
probability of being treated so that's
called propensity score so if i have
prop uh probability of being treated
equal to 0.7 and someone else who is
untreated also has probability of being
treated at 0.7 match both of this and
compare their outcome
uh people have shown this that this
works in general when you are interested
in estimating average treatment effects
however this is as you can think
susceptible to modern specification
because you need a model for
this probability function right so you
might be fitting a logistic regression
or something of your choice and if that
model is wrong then you're
you kind of have
misestimation there
same way people can match on something
called prognostic score which is
uh
a function which you would estimate by
fitting x with uh respect to the
outcomes of the control group
again model specification and this is
not interpretable and i actually touch
on this point why this is not
interpretable i have a slide which shows
it's not interpretability
the last is generic matching uh it tries
to learn distance matrix somehow but it
doesn't
go very well in producing
individualized estimates or you know
fine grain estimates of treatment
effects so what we are interested in the
whole process is you want really high
accuracy and we want interpretability
simultaneously i'll convince you that we
can get that
and so the whole procedure over here is
uh is trying to do that it's called most
and the idea is
pretty simple if you if you don't
remember anything from this talk after
the slide but remember this one line
that that's my biggest achievement so
the basic idea of malts is
let's learn an interpretable business
metric first
and then do nearest neighbor matching
using the distance meter uh because we
are learning using the observed data in
some very nice way
it allows
for high accuracy
and because we have chosen interpretive
business metric and in matching we are
matching like you like using nearest
neighbor matching it is by definition
interpretable
and still convince you but if you don't
remember anything after any word i say
after this this is one thing you should
remember
and maybe care about when you're doing
data science uh in the future
okay you're gonna harsh are you gonna
cover
what a good definition for stretch
that's that's something that's that i'm
still trying to figure out what does
they mean by a stretch
right so uh
i let me answer it right away uh so by
stretch
uh we
so stretch over here means distance
matrix loosely
uh but why do we call it stretch so you
can think of the classic uh euclidean
norm where we are calculating x
1 minus x 2 whole square right
instead of doing
x 1 minus x 2 whole square plus
say for all the dimensions
what if we would weight some of the
dimensions higher let's say we really
want to match tightly on
h but we say that we really we don't
really care about if we match really
tightly on
for example
uh
how many uh
how many uh toys they have for some
reason
then you are weighting them differently
that translates in
in linear algebra to stretching more age
and compressing
uh the the toys covariate and that's why
we call it stretch i'll formally
introduce what stretch means but you can
think of that as distance matrix for now
so matching after learning a distance
matrix is maybe
an alternative title to this
but mark i i i guess uh you have been in
this field long enough and you know how
retro memes work where you start with an
acronym and kind of
try to fit it back so this is a retronym
i would say
okay so uh recall that we uh
we had this unit i
which was treated and so that's why this
y i zero was
missing we
we didn't observe it
and we only observe y i uh which is
equal to y i one you want to find an
almost identical twin of unit i
but which has the
t j equal to zero right so we want to
find unit j which is very similar on x
i's
almost same on x
x and x y are almost same but t i has
opposite treatment t j is opposite to t
i so this is control this is treated
now we can say because x i is same as x
j
their y's
might be similar and the idea is
we're making an assumption that if your
x's are similar your wise are similar
which is a classic assumption you make
also in machine learning
then we can use the outcome of j
as our estimate of y i 0
because
y i 0 and y g 0 would be close and the
difference of y i and y j would be my
estimate of treatment of n this is the
broad idea of matching estimation using
matching
we're gonna take
a
seven second pause here and we'll move
forward
questions
yes harsh uh quick question um
does this happen very often when
x i
very similar to xj because
but you know
not only they are very similar but also
you always can find two different units
goes to two different
routes right so that's a that's an
excellent question and uh
this is kind of a twofing question you
asked
can you always find an xg which is
similar to x i so it depends on the
definition of similar and we are
actually going to
figure out how to define similar in in
this whole talk first uh but there are
cases when you can actually not find any
xg which is similar to x i and so you
give up and say that hey
with this observed data set
it is not possible for it is not
possible for me to give a good estimate
of treatment effect and that's a fair
thing to say right so let's say everyone
who uh
who gets above 1500 in sat
decides to go for higher education
then you would not find anyone
who has
scored 1500 but has not gone for higher
education and so you cannot see
what would happen if they hadn't gone
for higher education
right so
that that might happen
and that that's a that's a classic
problem of
overlap where the cheated group and the
control group are very different
uh in this whole setup we
assume or we restrict ourselves into
space where
we can
find treated and control group with
with some overlap so the probability is
that i will receive treatment given my
axis is
strictly away from zero and one it's not
either zero or one
so with large enough data set i can find
someone who's similar to me that's the
idea
does that answer the question
yeah it does um as you said with very
large data sets
yeah so in in some cases i i i guess so
the whole idea of this method is
try to find let's say if you have a 100
dimensional data set but you somehow
realize that only three or four or ten
covert it's really important to match on
other 90 are not important to match on
the idea of whole project is to learn
the distance matrix which
really
weighs
this 10 covets with a lot of weight
and then downwards the other 90. and how
do you do it correctly that's the idea
and that's that's because in a lot of
causal different scenarios such as you
can imagine vaccine trials or mother and
smoking sample or self-improve
the data set size is typically small
compared to classic machine learning
tasks so the data set size might be
thousands or tens of thousands of
patients or units not more than that
while in a classic machine learning
scenario you will have uh
probably 100 000 to a million
data points right
let's say if you're training a neural
network or something like that
so that's why this has to work well with
limited data and that's why we want to
learn a distance meter
so
forget about every math on the slide
what we essentially want
is to estimate treatment effect t
uh capital tau
i
prime so tau prime is the estimate and
tau y is the true treatment of time
right
we want this estimate of treatment
effect using our procedure to be as
close to tau i as possible
so we want this
estimate to actually
the ideal thing is to be actually equal
to tau i but as i already convinced you
before knowing this ta y is impossible
it's it's impossible
because
we do not observe the counter factor we
do not observe y i zero for
uh unit i right and so we do not know
the star y
so this quantity is not
like we cannot minimize this because we
cannot really quantify this
what we can rather do is apply triangle
inequality and say
the y minus tau y prime is how well can
i estimate
y i one and how well can i estimate y a
zero now for all the treated units i
actually observe true y i one
right so if i were to estimate them
using nearest neighbor
what's my error there and for all the
control units i can i observe y i zero
if i were to estimate them using
nearest neighbors
what's my error
uh in doing that that's my loss for the
control units right so
for the treated units i can estimate the
first quantity for the control and
second estimate the second quantity and
so if i define my loss as
how much error do i make
uh
conditional on
this this quantity then i can calculate
this loss
more formally speaking this loss is
nothing but
the summation of
how much misprediction is there
in estimating my outcome
given my same
if i find people the same frequency
find unit j which is similar to i using
distance matrix d m x i x j right so
this is a listen to x and x j and m is
what this v parameters is distance
matrix x and my loss is difference of y
i and y j
because j is now estimating the outcome
of y
that's my loss does that make sense
would it be
correct to summarize this is saying
you're simply finding whatever
similarity metric you can come up with
that will minimize that will maximize
your ability to predict outcome on the
basis of nearest neighbors seriously
exactly okay
yeah exactly so
this is reducing the causal influence
problem to
two separate uh nearest neighbors
problem and learning a distance matrix
which can allow us to nearest neighbors
in a really good way
right and
the the way we estimate this y
phi prime i t is
we find nearest neighbors of
uh i based on x i
and then we do this weighted sum
this is this is this is i guess you've
seen all of some form of this at some
point of time in machine learning
here we are adapting this thing for
causal influence uh and specifically the
part where causal influence comes in is
this step of reduction where we can do
first part for treated and the second
part for control that's the that's the
major difference
now
once you can calculate this loss you can
find an m which
minimizes minimizes this loss and that's
our optimal distance matrix
it is not trivial because
you are
sort of trying to find
a distance matrix which is not the
classic quantity of optimization and a
lot of optimization problems but i'm not
going to go in detail of how did we
optimize because it's going to bore
people to death
on the contrary let's let's talk about
what distance matrix form we choose and
why is this really called stretch so
let's say if we assume our distance
matrix
between i and j to look something like x
i minus x j so think of them as vector
uh x i minus x j transpose times n times
x i minus x g right so m is something
that we are trying to learn over here
and if we constrain m to be a diagonal
matrix
then each diagonal entry tells me how
important that covariate is
and also if you think of this in a
linear algebra term you're trying to
stretch this covariate space so if
some of the covariates are really
important
you want to give really high weight to
their mismatch
you want to say that if there's a
mismatch on that covariate then i want
to give a lot of penalty to that
but if i'm really different on
non-important co-weights such as tonal
lens then i don't want to give that much
penalty for that so i would compress and
give a really small weight to that does
that make sense
powers
yep awesome
uh so this is broadly the algorithm of
faults and let me walk you through the
the big big steps of algorithm you have
the data you split it into let's say
beta random split
use one part for training this is
contrary to classic machine learning
where you use beta minus one parts for
training and
one part for validation here we use one
part for training and rest beta minus
ones plus we call them estimation that
right
so we learn a distance matrix using the
training set find an m opt and then do
nearest neighbor matching
for all the units in the estimation set
create match groups
and then estimate conditional average
treatment effects so conditional average
treatment effect is condition on x
my opposite covariates
what is my treatment effect so if you
condition on it and then take the
average of outcomes that's my
conditional average treatment
now as you can imagine you can repeat
this thing data times because each time
you change the training set you're going
to get a different
n
so you can repeat this beta times and
then you can repeat the whole procedure
alpha 10 because you don't want an
estimates to be biased by how you split
it the first time this is mainly for
smoothing and then once you have done
this you get two things this is
essentially a bootstrapping procedure so
you get
the variances from this
also uh you you kind of unbiased you
unbias your method based on what
training set you had chosen
in the first round
that's why this reputation like this
repeats alpha and beta allows you to do
this now the obvious question is is that
costly well
yes but not extremely costly because
your training set is small so the the
first step of learning distance matrix
is really fast
and
the the beautiful part about this is we
actually need a really small training
set because of the way we are optimizing
things
it's a it's a really simple optimization
set up
we're
we are learning
relatively fewer parameters we don't
really need large training sets and
because this is small the whole first
step is super
fast
the second step is of course nearest
neighbor matching which is which can be
done in order and log in just super fast
and so this whole procedure is not that
expensive and can be done in a
reasonable uh time
so that's that's all is the algorithm of
malls if you have any questions yeah
feel free to interrupt me or i should
take actually a minute break
yeah i have a quick question so
it would seem that you could find an
optimal set of parameters for your
training set um for any given
training set
so if i just repeat this process like
alpha times it would seem that like i
would just
um yeah i guess i don't understand like
how do you choose like do you see you
call it learning so i don't understand
like how you call like what is the step
size i mean you go for the beta minus
one splits but
how do you choose like how much to
update the
um parameters in your matrix ah i see
that's a great question so
for each round each of the beta rounds
you actually find a totally different m
opt
a completely different completely new
mrt
and you don't combine them right away so
for that specific round you use that
round specific m op to do nearest
neighbor matching and estimate treatment
effects or causal reference
for each beta you will have
beta different estimates of m ops and
for
if you repeat this whole procedure alpha
times then you will have alpha times
beta estimates of this distance matrix
now what that captures is
the uncertainty in my estimation of
distance metric right because
each time i'm i'm shuffling the data set
you can think of this as shuffling the
data set
i'm getting a different estimate so it's
capturing it it's essentially a
bootstrap procedure a stratified
bootstrap procedure which is capturing
the uncertainty in the opt i'm doing and
that uncertainty is essentially being
translated in the uncertainty of my
treatment effect estimates so that
allows me to uh that that
this
whole procedure allows me to somehow
get the confidence intervals on
treatment effects as well or uncertainty
quantification on trade methods as well
does that answer to the question
okay yeah i think it does so you said
you get beta
like
um beta minus one of these m up matrices
and then
cross this alpha times do you just
continue to like um
yeah take them individually and use them
to calculate the uncertainties
exactly exactly yeah
i guess i guess
what uh
brent
was also asking uh
was
when to stop i mean when when
when should we choose the alpha to stop
i mean if you have the
uncertainty
you know like means of time adopted to
m up already
how do you know it's good to go
i mean
that's an excellent question so in other
simpler words how big my alpha should be
is your question right
my l and the answer to that is the
bigger the alpha the better
often
in practice we have found that if you
repeat it two to three times that's good
enough
uh because and so
beta equal to five and alpha equal to
two or three
seems to work well because that gives
you like 10 to 15 estimates uh different
estimates
uh
of your distance matrix and condition
average treatment effects
uh but the larger the alpha the better
actually and so if you have time and
machine power to because you can do the
whole process in parallel right there is
nothing stopping you from doing this
whole process in parallel it's it's an
independent
run each time so if you have resources
and time you can actually run it like
thousands of time and that will give you
really tight intervals and really tight
estimates
uh it will really smooth things out for
you
so yeah the more the merrier is the
answer
depending on your resources
hey hey harsh does this
work for something like
you know various transactions or bidding
like i like i'm sitting here and
somebody bid on my uh desk that i'm
selling
you know and i'm trying i'm thinking
well i can accept the offer right now
or not and make it you know and make a
counteroffer but i don't know what'll
you know i don't know what would have
happened
right i mean i can only choose to trade
once right
yeah yes you can in fact that
so uh you're absolutely right you can
and in fact that is one of the primary
motivations of this is
we assume that the agents in
microeconomics are rational in in a
bidding game or rational however a lot
of times the agents acting there do not
really know the downstream effect of
their actions
right right you want to maximize the
utility but they really don't know what
it will lead to
so uh yes you can use this and that's
this is also used in a lot of uh
econometric applications right which
tries to just do this do something
similar so you can use this absolutely
you could also use the the 37 rule
yeah for my problem i could do that i'm
thinking more about like
you know i'm thinking of
in on wall street just people trying to
you know figure out what the best time
to trade is and
see if they can
come up with some better metrics for
best execution and things like that
oh so
if you're talking about wall street then
yeah all all bets are off so to speak
especially with the aforementioned high
frequency traders
yeah yeah that's that's my background
pre-pre
predatory you know practices for
everybody's normal trades
well i i just sell technology to those
guys i'm an arm stealer
i give them the really fast technology
harsh um
can i ask you uh you use a diagonal
matrix there and have you either uh
explored i mean obviously that sort of
makes an independent assumption and in
real life features are tightly dependent
and so forth have you either um looked
at a full
full uh yes we have or or
have you first pca transformed your data
to
essentially yes
yes we have done both and
actually i answered this question three
parts yes we have looked at the full one
we also have looked at the pc or
transformed uh covariate space
and
surprisingly in the in the simulation
results because in that's the only place
where we can actually look at the true
answers
we didn't find that the accuracy gain
from doing either of those two things is
significant enough that we should give
up our interpretability on uh this
distance matrix right because if it is
diagonal it's clearly interpreted as the
importance of covalent
the second answer is also on the
codependency or collinearity of
covariates so let's say i have one
covariate which is my scores in science
exam and the other coverage is my scores
in math exam and they're of course
correlated
matching tightly on one
will ensure matching tightly on another
so it is actually better for me because
i can quickly find a distance matrix
it's fine finding a good distance matrix
would be much easier for me if all of
them are highly correlated it's not a
problem it's a it's kind of
benefit for me if they are
highly correlated does that make sense
okay sure actually i was going to ask
then in the other direction if you
thought about um regularization
uh
imposing sparsity or something yes we so
we are imposing sparsity i did not write
over here just to keep the equations
clean uh we are imposing so uh there
isn't a frobenius norm loss on m op
because uh you can have as large m as
possible but we want it to be small and
we want it to be sparse and so the we we
also try to minimize uh there's a
there's a plus c times frobenius norm of
m probabilities norm is like the l
equivalent of
uh i know of matrices yeah
um okay cool thanks
awesome so i have been talking about
accuracy interpretability let me quickly
give you results about that right so
here uh there are we are looking at uh
five methods moles is our method bart
and causal forests are two black boxy
highly non-parametric method
propensity score and prognostics are
something that i talked about initially
right so there this two are matching
methods these two are not matching
methods
but highly non-parametric regression
based methods and then walls is our
method and the scenario is very simple
the treatment choice is function of
first two coverage x0 and x1
my outcome is a linear function of
x i and my treatment effect which is the
second term over here is linear term of
x i and the quadratic terms of x i and x
j
so it's fairly simple setup but it is
also a non-linear setup so it's
not something which is obvious like if
you feel linear regressions you will get
right answer that's not true over here
uh because there is a quadratic term
over here
right uh
and
let's see this graph so
in this plot on the y-axis you have
how much error is in our estimation so
the larger the verse the smaller the
better
and then on the
x-axis you have number of units in the
data set so 2 to the power 8 is 256
units in your total data set
uh and then we exponentially increase
them at each
job
and uh
not not kind of hyping too much but most
actually performs better than
state-of-the-art
uh
non-parametric causal inference methods
and also beats uh hands down uh the
prognostic sorry the prognostics current
the propensities for matching methods
in fact it performs much better till we
actually reach 2 to the power 12 units
and then later on also it continues to
perform as good as part
uh
bart is a non-parametric method it is
very data hungry and that's why
you might imagine it has a higher uh
error rate initially
but
this is quite convincing because all
this tells us moles performs on par with
the black box method
uh while being interpretable and i will
show you interpretability in a second
oh and by the way this is omni on
synthetic data because that's the only
place where we have access to true
treatment effects
awesome
and on interpretability these are three
levels of interpretability first you can
look at
you can actually estimate the
probability distribution of conditional
average treatment effects so there are
some units with higher treatment effects
and some unit with low what's the
heterogeneity in the distribution you
can look at that
so
uh this is that distribution on x-axis
you have different values of treatment
effect on y-axis you have a probability
density value you can think of this as a
histogram
the other thing which you can look at is
the distance measured right uh because
the distance matrix was essentially a
diagonal entry each of what i'm showing
over here is the box plots of
what different m ops gave us and here
here my beta is five and alpha is three
so i ran it 15 times i got different 15
uh m ops
what is the stretch for age education
savings and the interesting part here is
it is very important so this is for save
as self-help group data and it's very
important to match people
who
have savings account with other people
who have savings account
and people who do not have savings
account with other people who don't have
savings account
uh because savings having savings
account essentially sells says that
the bank has your information bank
trusts you because they you have a
savings account
the surprising part is it's not really
important to match on education
and this this is sort of
counterintuitive but
this is a case in this situation because
banks decision to give loan or not to
give loan is actually not a function of
how educated someone is
uh and again this is a
rural village data set from india so you
have to keep that in mind
uh that banks over there might not look
at education while giving uh loans
other things over here like cost ration
calculators like what it's a proxy for
your income and then gender
so they are fairly
important but not extremely important
the extreme importance of savings and
the unimportant one is the education so
that's the major thing of it
lastly i had been telling you that you
can actually look at the match groups
so let's look at them
uh here is a match which is constructed
by malls so the the unit of interest is
this
zero zero four uh it's an 18 year old
female who does not have a savings
account who is poover and is from the
cost of vc has 12 years of education
does not have a
is not participating in self-help group
does not have loan
imagine match her to
a 22 year old female who also does not
have savings account and a 21 year old
female who also does not have sleep
and they both get loans because they
both are partisan
now let's compare this to the match
group for the same unit constructed by
prognostics coordination right
prognostic score and propensity score
very analogous i just talked about them
this 18 year old female is first match
with a 56 year old male 1
and in the second case it's matched with
a 32 year old female who has a savings
account right so you can clearly look
into match groups and say that oh yeah
i know why this person was matched with
202 and 904 but i actually don't
understand why this unit was matched
with 321 and 874. they don't look
anything alike and so that's what i mean
by
even this matching methods which match
on some sort of summary of things are
not interpretable while malls
performs accurately and is interpretable
simultaneous
now a domain expert like an economist
can look at this match group and also do
a chart review so there might be some
data some history about these people
which cannot be captured by this
matching process right because these are
people people have stories so you can
look at the stories why they participate
and why that they're not participating
make a qualitative assessment of the
match
make sense of what's going on in in the
story that's why interpretability is
very important in this area
so just to
re like just to repeat myself uh moles
gives you three levels of
interpretability the macro one you can
look at the distance matrix you can look
at the distribution and the
heterogeneity of treatment effects
across units and lastly it's the micro
level interpretability or unit specific
interpretability where you can look at
the match groups and make sense of the
story that's going on
for that match crew
lastly how do you use mods right uh uh
five minutes i can quickly go over this
so you can find malts on almost a
matching exactly github page i have
shared my uh google slides link with all
of you all of you should have this link
if you want to use it
using with python is super easy it's a
quick pip install like one line and then
the api is also very easy right so once
you import import by malls
all you need to do is
uh save what your outcome is and what
what what column is your outcome and
what column is your treatment and then
give the data that's it it's like one
line and then it will give you the match
groups and the treatment effect for each
smash group along with the uncertainty
uh intervals
super easy to use super convenient for
uh both uh statisticians and
non-statisticians in different areas
the the almost matching exactly lab
group comprises of uh now two phd
students earlier there were three marco
vito and me
uh and the pis are cynthia i guess you
all know cynthia she's super famous
uh alex and sudeepa slipper is a
database person she helps us make our
methods really fast uh
and alex is a stats guy who helps us
with our theory
lastly all the pictures in the talk were
actually like clicked by me when i
visited uh these villages in india where
the story i told you about right so i
clicked them and i thank the non-profits
which allow me to
visit there and chat with locals over
there and thank you so much for
listening to me if you have any
questions i'm super happy to take that
yeah yeah i won harsh uh this is matt
have you have you worked with any of the
big
microlending organizations i mean it
sounded like you said india is made this
a government
thing but like i know world vision has
vision fund that operates in lots of
different countries
um
are any of them picking this up to try
to sort of prove out
their effectiveness
i
no they are not but
if you know anyone please connect me we
are actively seeking collaborators and
we really want uh this to like this word
to go out because we are interested in
deploying this method for real high
stakes decision problems where we can
make uh some
some substantial impact so please
connect us if you have any connections
yeah what's your email i'll connect you
i i was
yeah i'm good friends with the former
cio there
at world vision and
some of the some of my other friends ran
some of the
micro microfinance organizations i can't
think of their names right now the names
of the organizations but
um
sure i'm happy to connect you
thank you so much yeah uh
just
to make a word we are working with
doctors at massachusetts general
hospital where we are interested in
finding
if a drug treatment works for patients
in icu or not of course you cannot do
randomized trials in ico so we are using
moles there and uh like the match groups
i showed here we are using this match
groups to
and doctors are actually going back and
looking at the doctor's notes or chart
reviews to say
if this match groups make sense or they
don't make sense and what qualitative
judgment we can make about whom to treat
with this treatment and whom not to
treat with this so this is actually
being actively used at massachusetts
general hospital
by neurophysicians who are there
cool
very good
thank you so much i guess i'm
right on time there yes yes right on
time
we actually have one minute for one more
question if anybody has any
all right if not uh we can go
ahead to start our lightning talk
session
uh mark you want to get
this over
see
sure
let me share my screen
uh
screen
two
see if this works
can you see see my jupiter notebook
yeah yes i can oh by the way before you
present him mark i want to say thank you
amanda for
attending because i saw your
heading out
um
just want to say thank you and uh i'll
talk to you soon
all right go ahead mark sorry okay
uh
this is this is just a python thing i i
was answering somebody's question online
and realized oh well this would make for
a real quick lightning talk so
uh they they were uh wanting to to
compare words in a sentence to
a dictionary that they had populated
both the keys of the dictionary and the
values of the dictionary
and really
the
the the rule of thumb here is the
dictionary
while while the keys are a fast look up
the the values would not be so don't use
a dictionary use a set object
in python
uh
because
the value the values
you have to search
linearly uh through through the values
to do a match and you would expect if
there is a match to to to reverse half
the number of entries
um there
so i'm just going to take you through
some some different ways you can
populate a set
right now the dictionary only has
two two items in it
uh m for mark and f for fred if you're
curious fred is my brother uh so if i
iterate the keys i can i can add them if
i can iterate the values and i can add
them and then i've got a set object with
the keys and the values from the
dictionary
easy easy peasy but
we can do this with a single iteration
uh by iterating the items of the
dictionary which which is a tuple uh
with the the key and the value
and uh do
uh
an ad within the for loop
uh
an ad of the first and the second item
in the uh
the tuple
and we once again get
the output our set object is populated
uh
for a readability standpoint instead of
uh
accessing the tuple by index
we can with the four with the for loop
specify
uh two value two variables uh and unpack
the
uh the tuple and this makes it more
readable
but
when you start when you start
doing things with data
this is what i tell
my database classes
think in sets don't don't think in terms
of iteration
think in sets i want to i want the set
of all x
um
instead of
uh iterating through and finding if if
an item is an x for instance
so
here
the uh the set function the set function
that creates a set object will take an
iterable
and
so we can then
uh get the keys in and then with an
update statement update method get the
values in so we're
not really doing iteration at this point
to create the set
and then
we can leverage uh the inner tools
uh library which has a chain method
and here we we can uh use that one
set
set function but chain uh both the keys
and the values
for the
for that and it'll bring it all in and
once in one statement
but
if you're using the chain
they actually have a from iterable
the method itself has a method uh from
iterable where it if i supply the items
in the dictionary which are the keys and
the values
that
that that irritable
uh
will be used to populate the the set
so within one uh one statement no inter
no iteration on my part python iteration
on my part
we have a set
um and if you do this kind of thing in
in several in several places you may you
may want to uh
assign the from iterable chain dot from
interval uh to
uh its own variable so that you can use
it in several different places
in your in your code so
conclusion we can eliminate iteration in
our python code
in many in many places
and
any questions about that
yeah i got one question for you mark um
where did you um
uh start thinking i mean
what inspired you
uh you know uh to
to
play with this set in the first place i
mean
oh i was answering somebody's question
online and
they just they had addiction they had a
dictionary and they wanted to
um compare the words and and their text
to the keys and the values of the
dictionary so it was somebody else's
problem
and and then i realized oh well there's
very
simple ways of doing it but there then
there are more pythonic ways of doing it
and
so i i like to step people through the
simple to
[Music]
pythonic
path as it were
wonderful wonderful
okay uh
two more two more things
um
there is a live there is a library oh oh
oh wait wait wait wait wait oh oh
ah
hang on a second
uh
let me see if i can
do this again ah okay
come back up here
oh no what's uh my extension
didn't you um
oh my exte where are my extensions uh
manage extensions
oh
kodiga gotta turn it up gotta turn it on
there you go
okay
so
um
if this works right
i
i installed a
google chrome extension
called kodiga
and it does static it does static
analysis
um it
originally designed to do static
analysis of code
in a github repository but it can also
do
static analysis
in
in
the
the place that you're the place that
you're at
uh
when you
on localhost
i've turned it on
let's see if it works
if i have to
are you losing all those uh
running
results from your uh
i might i might lose them but i'm trying
to show the static at the static
analysis
ah there it is ah
here we go
so this little uh icon this spinning
c
in the lower right hand corner of this
code window
no oh
uh do you see that and it underlined it
underlined two
um
two statements uh consider iterating the
dictionary directly instead of calling
keys and it wants to have a new line
missing so these would be pep um
uh
uh
yeah
python
coding python coding practices
interesting uh now it's not perfect
because
once i once i have um
once i have a
jupiter
uh
markdown cell
then
it's it's it's gonna say i can't find
the i can't find what d is my dictionary
because it's not in the same cell it's
not perfect
undefined variable d
because the dictionary the dictionary
was was up here in the first cell and
once we get down here
into
this cell
um
it it doesn't it doesn't know about
the the dictionary uh variable the
dictionary object
um
so uh
it's it's a way of bringing static and
static uh code analysis into
either your your browser
or
what whether it's jupiter jupiter hub
jupiter lab
or
enter your get put having github
repository it can go into your github
repository and do this same type of
static static analysis
all right
and
something that i saw i sent it down to
doug cline in wilmington at unc
wilmington
newspaper newspaper uh library
and it will
do some text it will do some text uh
processing including
scraping a web page for you
showing you know scraping out
eliminating all the html
and
doing
natural language processing on the page
and here's here's nlp
and here where are my where are my
keywords after doing some nlp
and then giving you giving you
uh summary what so from from the nlp
what is the summary what is the summary
of the the text that you have just
scraped
um and
i haven't i haven't used it but it's
something that uh i thought was good
enough
to um
to show doug klein down in wilmington
and
for those of for those of you who have
used uh
uh
pycharm
pycharm is written by jetbrains and they
they're
uh putting it out on a bait on a beta
test of data spell
which is an exploratory data analysis
tool and i have just unboxed it this
week so i i i don't have a good uh
a good demo for this tool yet but i i
thought i would at least let you know
that you can download data spell for
free and try it out for yourself
and
that
is what i wanted to show
yeah mark can you please uh
paste the link
in the chat
whereas
showing the natural language processing
summary you know
um so that people can read that through
sure
yeah there you go
thank you
text scraping and processing and
uh
codeiga
uh
code analysis
i think uh there is a question coming up
for you
mark
okay uh ben was asking why did you
choose to set a variable as to set
to set method
not quite sure what does it mean
okay hang on
uh
why did you choose to set a variable
s to the set method oh um
for for doing for doing process
instead of
i i wanted to create a set
the object is to
create or populate a set variable
from the dictionary's keys and values
so i that's that's why that's why
i'm i'm using i was setting s equals to
set
so that that would be persistent uh for
use later during the the text parsing
was is that
ben was that what
you wanted to know
i think ben is on mute
um
okay
okay can you speak to that ben
hello
we can't hear you ben
um
yeah but you still cannot hear
oh i think ben has
something in the chat
can you use list
so there is a
there is at least
a list of function can you use list
marks
[Music]
uh you could use you could use list uh
instead of a set but you your your
searching of the list is going to be
linear even if you use the in
operator in python it's a linear it's a
linear search so you you can expect
an n in divided by two set length
divided by two
uh performance whereas uh
the dictionary keys and the set object
themselves are an order one
because you're you're hashing the string
that you're looking for
and it's compared compared to hashes
that were already done
inside the set or dictionary key object
all right i would love to talk more but
uh we are uh running out of time i've
actually already gone over one minute so
um i was
i would like to thank you all to um
you know by attending this meeting i'm
so grateful everyone is keeping
consistently attending um
and that's i mean uh i'll be here and
mark is here jean is here and uh you
know you know our email address right uh
any
you know questions came up please uh you
know let us know uh from the meetup or
from you know any uh you know uh contact
information you'd like to have
hey a quick question i don't know about
anybody else but i was getting periodic
and random
uh four or five second audio blackouts
um all during all the presentations did
anybody else experience that or is that
just
me
i'm i'm good here uh i don't see
blackouts do you see anything
i didn't have it i didn't have any
interruptions or slowdowns uh this time
i've had them in the past but but this
this has been a good a good presentation
okay
it must
be cool
all right thanks guys thanks for
attending
uh by the way our next meeting gonna be
on this uh
january
the ninth i believe uh
more to come more to come all right
thanks thank you uh merry christmas
happy thanksgiving happy new year happy
new year everyone happy new year and
merry christmas
all right